that preserves some minutes in case they
need to bring him back in the last five
or six minutes Jordan back door love
vert excellent communication with Jordan
and Levert just ahead not enough to get
levert to the rent was extended playing
time with Dinwiddie still on the bench
levert the palo by move off the dribble
little behind the back in tight quarters
love girly shot on target Coolidge
controls the tip get it ahead
intercepted by Williams behind the back
but chiozza steps it levert always got
it a three so that other people have to
make plays
Gio's a high pass the Wawel Kappa row
working around the perimeter levert are
we spoking 21 points 21 minutes six
point Boston lead love Bert hard to the
hole 109 105 Celtics look at this pass
beautiful one-handed pass off the
dribble earning this opportunity for the
big club coming up next on TNT the 76ers
take on the Lakers levert oh we can't
miss Terrace levert is smoking hot
[Applause]
two-point game 24 points in the fourth
quarter 38th overall
Lebert
tie game Chuck walk is down to nine one
minute gone by and overtime the verdant
around a chalet banks at home carats
levert past 42 with 3:38 to go in OT
Nets lead by two levert off the stutter
the floater is good at a foul
Kerris levert has it stuck on automatic
he missed that free throw now 9 of 14
but he gets his own rebound levert leans
he's not human
Tara's levert the banker 10 to shoot
[Applause]
Laverne back in fade oh he's a one-man
wrecking crew
[Music]
just size advantage their turn and get
it up over the top everything going for
Karis levert right